and we're hearing that the shushing that
you're all doing to each other when you
were in there what do you think could
potentially happened I mean you can't
help but go to the worst-case scenario
the worst fears were that there was a
gunman who could have potentially been
in the restaurant and that we were
cornered in there to be be honest and
even just thinking about it now it still
gives me chills because we just had
nowhere to go and after you after the
terrible incident in Paris you just cut
that help go to that worst-case scenario
so it was terrifying in the worst thing
was we just had no idea what was going
on no information was coming in more
people were arriving in tears a few of
them seemed to have some minor injuries
but we had no idea what had happened and
actually after about a half an hour in
there they they told us that you know it
was fine it was probably just an
accident that someone had driven into
the crowds but it didn't appear to be
serious so so we let it we told you that
was that the authority no it wasn't we
were hoping that there might be some
authorities there and we were reluctant
to leave until we saw some police
outside it was them it was just people
working in in the restaurant chefs and
the managers